Someone said to me recently after a show,
they said, “Chris, can you say hi to my wife
after the show?”
You have a wife and you came to see me?
This is not for people with wives.
This is for theatre people who don’t get cast.
♪ Driscoll’s or a gerbil? ♪
♪ Should I get a Driscoll’s or a gerbil? ♪
♪ Should I get a Driscoll’s? ♪
I speak hyperbolically quite a bit
for comedic effect.
Is we gonna ride on horses?
Thank you for choosing Delta.
It doesn’t take a licensed psychologist
to tell you that something’s up.
That’s good, buddy.
Chris, my daughter loves your special.
Love you, baby.
Can’t believe you’re in jail.
We’re gonna need you to get real close up
on the camera.
Now we are stuck with these
unspeakable horrors.
Who am I?
Are you gonna fill me in on what just happened?
My mom, she always wanted, like, a J. Crew son.
Instead what she got is
the cheapest escort from Arizona.